je ne partage pas votre vision même si
les faits que vous évoquez notamment
pour votre collègue sénatrice sont
totalement insupportable inacceptable et
j'ai demandé au préfet de prendre langue
avec elle pour que tous les moyens
soient mis évidemment pour garantir sa
liberté d'expression sa liberté de dire
et de combattre comme elle le souhaite
comme elle le veut non pas seulement
parce que les sénatrices et ce serait
déjà une excellente raison mais tout
simplement parce que dans ce pays nous
devons garantir cette liberté
d'expression mais je ne veux pas vous
laisser dire que les voyous pourrait
aujourd'hui tenir la dragée haute face à
notre police ou de gendarmerie
chaque jour chaque nuit chaque fois que
la police est appelée elle vient chaque
fois elle intervient on a beaucoup parlé
ces derniers jours hélas depuis de
longues années de la question des
violences urbaines comme vous je les
dénonce
mais je fais en sorte que la police soit
renforcée j'évoquais tout à l'heure la
politique de 10000 recrutements
nécessaires pour que nous soyons
présents partout y compris dans les
quartiers et nous sommes présents
partout y compris dans les quartiers
analysons pas les événements médiatiques
comme une ligne une tendance en matière
de violences urbaines si on regarde par
rapport à l'an dernier nous sommes sur
une constante y compris d'ailleurs
pendant la période du confinement à
l'exception de l'ile-de-france où nous
avons connu une augmentation
significative mais ça n'était pas le cas
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
mais à chaque fois
police et gendarmerie malgré le risque
de guet-apens il y en a eu 120 ont été
identifiées pendant la perte du conte du
confinement comme étant des guet-apens à
chaque fois police et gendarmerie sont
intervenus et je ne pourrai pas vous
laisser penser qu' il n'ya pas
d'interpellation au contraire des
interpellations il y en a eu plus de 300
individus pendant la seule période du
confinement ont été interpellées dans le
cadre de ces violences urbaines des
condamnations ont déjà eu lieu des
condamnations à la prison ferme des
condamnations avec dépôt immédiat et
écrous immédiat voilà la réalité mais il
n'empêche que c'est un combat que nous
devons mener pas seulement monsieur le
sénateur par l'interpellation mais aussi
par la prévention par la présence et je
ne souhaite pas opposer la nécessité
d'avoir une police de sécurité du
quotidien qui s'appuie sur le travail
des élus pour porter une ambition pour
les quartiers les plus difficiles de
notre pays est une
j team répression les deux doivent aller
de pair